donc là comment tu le sens l'arrêt de
bus bah ça fait comme une
boîte c'est la fin là tu vois alors
comment je le sens en fait quand je
passe devant ça fait vraiment en fait on
peut faut vraiment comparer ça à l'ombre
quelque chose et l'arrêt de bus oui
c'est l'ombre elle est vraiment fort en
fait ça fait vraiment une grosse grosse
ombre et en plus il est en vert le vert
renvoie mieux le son et c'est une des
raisons que on sent mieux que si c'était
des feuillages par exemple
voilà là pareil tu vois il y aurait pas
de localisation je serai obligé de taper
dans le mur pour savoir donc autant nez
voir avec ses oreilles c'est possible
grâce à un sixième sens que les
non-voyants peuvent développer et qu'on
appelle les colocalisations et avec un
peu d'entraînement même les personnes
qui voient peuvent maîtriser cette
technique vous allez voir le cerveau est
fascinant il y en a beaucoup qui pensent
que
qui pense que je compte les pas pour
savoir contourner mais non pas du tout
c'est grâce à l'ombre du son finalement
à l'écolocalisation que je peux savoir à
quel moment il faut tourner là je sens
un truc dans le fond c'est quoi là-bas
c'est une entrée de quelque chose tu
vois mais il est loin ou pas
non mais tu vois je sais pas non
derrière ce truc là encore il y a
quelque chose d'autre mais je peux pas
savoir si je devais faire le même chemin
avec les oreilles fermées je t'attendrai
vraiment je t'attonnerai pas droit comme
je serais comme un gars qui est bourré
je pense
on pense même que nos ancêtres
utilisaient et maîtriser déjà la
technique de l'écolocalisation il y a
des dizaines de milliers d'années
notamment pour visiter les grottes
sombres et obscures et là par exemple
c'est autre chose c'est vraiment une
information supplémentaire mais ça ne
parasite pas la localisation des des
obstacles des murs tout ça faut savoir
quand il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
brouilles ça parasite quand même alors
les moments où il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de bruit les moments où il y a la
tempête la Bourgogne a une forte tempête
avec de la pluie de la neige là aussi il
y a quelque chose c'était quoi là
j'en sais rien
je sais pas ah ouais bah c'est ça
mais en fait parce que l'arbre il est
assez large par contre si c'était un
poteau tout fin j'aurais du mal à le
sentir vite fait comme ça il faut
vraiment être très près je me suis pas
du tout entraîné aucun entraînement sur
l'entraînement finalement c'est le
cerveau qui qui l'a que cela posait tout
seul en fait moi je pense à partir du
moment le cerveau
il arrive plus à percevoir son
environnement
il fait le tour c'est un peu comme si
l'analysé tout ce que on a comme sens et
il essaye de développer toutes sortes de
sens pour qu'on puisse percevoir
l'environnement
du coup il utilise pas la zone de son
cerveau qui gère les informations
visuelles et qu'on appelle le cortex
visuel et bien son cortex visuel c'est
directement connecté à son cortex
auditif qui lui gère les sons résultats
c'est un peu comme s'il pouvait voir
avec ses oreilles et ça c'est possible
parce que le cerveau est plastique il
peut s'adapter parfois des changements
d'environnement je vous l'avais dit le
cerveau est fascinant